foreign
strike and strike and strike and strike
and strike
in the name of jesus anything it would
be of an antichrist spirit we break it
right now in the name of jesus every
antichrist spirit we break it right now
angels are being released right now
angels are being dispatched they're
coming here in the name of jesus from
south america they're coming here
they're coming here
[Music]
until you have victory for every enemy
that is aligned against you let there be
that we would angels are being released
right
now being dispatched they're coming here
in the name of jesus in south america
they're coming here they're coming here
they're coming
sound of here
victory victory victory in the quarters
of heaven and the quarters of heaven
victory victory victory victory victory
victory
[Laughter]
angels are being released right now
angels are being dispatched they're
coming here in the name of jesus
[Music]
[Applause]
gold
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
for the land
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my
[Music]
oh boy
let's remind you that we have a
tremendous bonus bonus show
oh boy
flippy from indiana
flippy from indiana please unmute you
are on the air my friend all right can
you hear me
yes i can
hey david it's me um i just was
wondering if you've ever reconsidered
making it only fans sorry if i if i've
done making an omelette what no no
making it only fans uh you know uh
burning season is over and it's time for
you to show us shoes
zucchini that's very clever no listen um
i think i'd i'd be more likely
uh i'd be more likely to show my my
granny smith apples than any zooks
floppy dukes flippy floppy uh floppy
[Music]
wow really an incredible day i can't
believe we're all here today uh after
such an incredible introduction there
we are going to be setting the stage for
the kyle rittenhouse murder trial which
starts on monday november 1. we plan
live coverage
and i am not feeling particularly well i
don't know if optimistic is even really
the right word because what we want is
justice to be done
but i'm not feeling like it's a
situation that will lend itself to
justice being done
clearly cleanly and fairly and we're
gonna explain
many of the reasons why
momentarily okay so i'm so glad that
you're joining me today we have so much
to go over yes it is another
uh we're up to three three streams in no
wait hold on four streams in a row
sunday monday tuesday wednesday very
strong elements of streaming
and we are debuting
a new coupon code today that code is
elements of bathrooms elements of
bathrooms and that is the code today at
joinpackman.com
um so much taking place and and we're
we're really gonna
go deep on the kyle rittenhouse stuff
and i'm gonna wait a few moments for
people to connect and and for all of
that
um where to start
i uh i was at i saw it being discussed
in the chat before we started
how many people are we banning during
the average stream it's really more of a
question for the moderators i know that
casually paying attention to the chat in
between the different things i'm doing
i'll typically ban
three or four people during every single
stream now the moderators are also doing
their own work
um
moderating as as is the task assigned to
them
so i don't know it could be 15
people-ish or something like that as an
example today i banned one person before
we even started
um
i don't you know we don't we're not
going to get into we're not going to
publicize what they did but already one
person was banned even before the
introduction started which is really
quite remarkable uh takes skill to get
banned before there is even really a
stream substantively happening uh also i
got a couple emails saying
david we really like the food related
content the ice cream and the cheese can
you recommend a snack
i i don't know i mean it's kind of a
weird uh it's kind of a weird thing um
a snack
um
here's an interesting snack okay i
didn't develop this also i don't know if
snacks are
discovered or created
it's really kind of an epistemological
metaphysical question that maybe exceeds
the scope of today's stream i don't know
if they're um created or discovered
um it's sort of like is a chess opening
created or discovered it's always
available on the board
so was it really being created or are we
just finding it
um it was fire created or discovered
it existed
uh okay anyway here's an interesting
snack i think people will like i i find
this to be a pretty uh healthy snack
well-rounded etc okay
here's the deal
dates with salted almonds or almonds or
almonds as some very strange people
pronounce it here's the way you do it
you get yourself good dates i prefer
either israeli dates or saudi arabian
dates a viewer once actually sent me
when we still accepted packages at our
mail handling service now packages go
right into the trash it became too much
of a thing i know hassan opens packages
on stream and i should look at doing
that but um we had a different very
different situation okay
you get yourself some dates
make sure to remove the pit
okay i i didn't do this the other day
and bid into a pit and it was not so
good
and then i almost unilaterally am
against salted nuts if i want the salt
i'll add it later but i don't need to
buy it with the salt i might want it
unsalted okay but in this particular
case i recommend salted almonds and this
is the snack you cut the dates are quite
large you cut the date into probably
three pieces you remove that pit
each of the three pieces you grab a
salted almond and you bite it
simultaneously and you get the sweetness
of the date
and that kind of fibrous texture
you get the um
crunch of the nut
the protein of the nut
as well as a little bit of that salt
that's a great snack guys
that's a great snack
uh
okay 50 people just cancelled
memberships because of the snack
recommendation that's too bad
all right well
that's my um
that's my that's my recommendation okay
good
um what else did i have here oh snacks
we did oh okay
before we get into the kyle rittenhouse
stuff one other thing if you will permit
me we've been having this whole
situation
you know i'm not going to refresh the
entire thing but i recommended this
black cherry ice cream black cherry
chocolate chip ice cream from a company
called graders not a sponsor i just love
the ice cream then we determined that
just about every grocery store seems to
be sold out of the black cherry in fact
yesterday another viewer sent me a
picture of the graders shelf in their
local uh freezer
uh at the grocery store
they had five flavors in total
four available empty shelf with the
black cherry so then another viewer told
me hey david you can order it online
and yesterday on the stream we looked at
this
and
six pints for eighty dollars is pretty
expensive okay check out this email that
i got this is so funny
um diane wrote to me
and said um
david sir sir he's better than i am
david sir we just ordered the six pack
of assorted flavors ice cream birthday
cake raspberry sorbet lemon sorbet
cookie dough chocolate chip caramel
macchiato dark chocolate brownie and
after shipping to colorado each pint is
18.33
this is insane
my husband and i love ice cream
and this brand is not available in our
part of the country we should be getting
it by friday thank you for the
recommendation we'll let you know how
good our flavors are we are proud
members of your show and watch you daily
we really at this point i think it would
be completely reasonable to do a sort of
mini influence campaign people should be
reaching out to graders on twitter
saying good sirs you are getting so much
free promotion on the david pakman show
let's do like a taste test or something
like that i think it would be pretty
interesting because at this point people
are just forking over uh this stuff
seems to be worth as much as gold in
some parts of the country it's amazing
1833 and it is star d kosher for people
who are concerned about that
um
uh
yeah
louis greater
has been doing it for a long long time
and full kosher certification let's in
fact see
want to make sure they have the right
rabbi involved here rabbi eli yahushuan
beautiful beautiful i love it yeah so
strongly kosher even and it they're
really hitting all the high marks so i
think it's a very very important ice
cream um at this point in time for
society okay few super chats did you
notice the guy from the charlie kirk
rally ask
when the get to use the guns not when do
they have to use the guns they're
itching to go yeah i have a full clip
about the charlie kirk fiasco it's on
the um youtube channel
by that logic nothing is ever created by
conscious beings thank you for strong
streams have a great rest of the week
why is congress such an effing wreck
we're going to lose in 22
dem's cup paid leave how did mansion
compromise
and david you are the snack wow
sir your reprogramming has gone too far
my wife bought me a chili blanket
through your referral link thanks david
wow
very much appreciate that thank you
thank you thank you
also want to say thanks to some really
great people including jen here who just
gifted another two subscriptions on
twitch the old tired road just resubbed
for six months and blaze king
just resubscribed for 12 months with the
message beta
also thank
also thanks to uh
john warwick i crack myself up that's
two three four five john warwick putting
us at five
um
okay very good
oh and sorry also thank you to
jules is cools
new member number six today if you're
just joining us new coupon whoa
new coupon code launched today
elements of bathrooms elements of
bathrooms that's happening on uh on the
website
not to dwell on cheese but i have to ask
have you ever tried humble fog yeah it's
a good humble fog's a good cheese
pretty very very very strong cheese for
sure
okay
let's get into oh no hold on a second i
do have
oh should i do the voicemail about the
destiny thing now or should i do it
later
let me hold off a little bit
i did mention
waste losing an opportunity to drive
heavy equipment when i was last in las
vegas nevada with sam cedar sam went and
rented heavy equipment i didn't go and i
regret it but this viewer very politely
sent me this message if i'm interested
in driving heavy equipment
um he's gonna hook me up check this this
is cool
oh whoops hold on we need audio
let's back it up here
hey mr pacman sir
this uh message for you i heard you were
interested in driving some heavy
equipment
whenever you're in texas give me a call
i'll hook you up
look at this beautiful truck guys i
would drive that if that was a stick
shift otherwise i'm not interested one
of these for you and
have a whole yard full of these guys
whole yard that might not let you drive
the big truck but
these yellow things
yeah
i'll find you a nice place to play with
them how about that huh
and a lot of people saying is this pedro
from colombia it is not it is not i know
that i understand why people are asking
hey mr pakman sir
okay
oh man i don't even know what i'm doing
sir
yeah
mr president sir okay
so that's cool i really like that
um and then there were some highlights
made from yesterday's stream but i don't
know that any of them hit my rant about
um
about kids menus let's take a look
this nope wasn't
daniel says unhinged leftist wages war
against kids menus yes exactly
thank you and welcome to kathleen jacobs
kathleen signing okay i don't know we're
against kids men whoa
about the 2020 election yeah as
unexciting as mcauliffe is
yunkin is a lunatic extremist okay all
right so those are some some moments
from yesterday's stream
um
not super sure on the relevance can i
can i take a moment just to say
something serious uh actually and before
i do that i want to say thanks to
patrick mims who just signed up on my
website new member and also alexandria
teal
is the first person ever to sign up with
the coupon code elements of bathrooms
elements of bathrooms thank you
alexandria new members seven and eight
love it
absolutely love it
um
okay listen here's the deal yesterday i
went on it was a pretty violent rant it
was pretty full on about how i'm against
kids menus and i believe kids menus make
kids picky eaters and all this stuff
i got
one super chat during the stream from an
autistic person saying that it was
offensive to them that i was against
kids menus and i don't even understand
the connection but they said i was being
incented insensitive to autistic people
and i said guys
this has nothing to do with autistic
people i got away from the topic i then
got an email after the stream
um
from another autistic person saying i
dismissed the concerns of an autistic
person
about kids menus
and
the kids menu
situation had nothing to do with autism
nothing to do with autism
i i i'm i'm what am i what's the word
i'm looking for i'm inferring
that for some autistic people
um
not having
predictable food
or too many different foods can be
stressful
and so i'm inferring maybe some autistic
people like the kids menu because it's
comforting at their level of autism to
have the same few items that's great
that's great
i wasn't talking about that
i wasn't talking about that at all it
was not any kind of attack on autistic
people okay so please please please
please that would never do that
um
all right
let's uh let's let's continue
uh thanks to live to roll for life as
well as abe of arizona wookie jack jen
here gifted another subscription andre
bavaria
um just signed up and is asking for
another beta vid audio clip
there you go
uh so that's five putting us at 13.
very much appreciate that also thank you
to maggie norris who just signed up on
the website joinedpakman.com and his new
member number 14. elements of bathrooms
all right let's jump right into the kyle
rittenhouse stuff okay what is the kyle
rittenhouse situation well let's just
start with the overview from the wiki
on august 25 2020 amid the kenosha
unrest precipitated by the police
shooting of jacob blake kyle rittenhouse
then 17 years old from illinois
went to kenosha shot and killed two
people wounded a third during multiple
confrontations at two locations he was
armed with a smith and wesson m p-15
rifle and one of the individuals shot by
rittenhouse had a handgun at the first
location rittenhouse was pursued by a
group a gunshot was fired into the air
by a third party kenosha resident joseph
rosenbaum lunged at ritton house and
tried to take his rifle
rittenhouse fired four times at
rosenbaum who died shortly afterwards
that's the first person 17 year old kyle
rittenhouse killed
okay now
notice i'm not saying murdered that's
what the trial is going to determine
killed
at the second location written house
tripped while fleeing a man kicked him
written house fired at the man twice but
missed this is an out of control
individual while still on the ground
protesters approached rittenhouse silver
lake resident anthony huber struck
rittenhouse with a skateboard and
struggled for control of his rifle
rittenhouse then fired at huber once
killing him
west allis resident gage grosskroitz
then approached rittenhouse while
holding a handgun
written house shot him once severing his
bicep rittenhouse was arrested and
charged with multiple counts of homicide
and unlawful possession of a firearm
another teen was arrested and charged
with unlawfully supplying written
house's rifle written house's attorney
say it was self-defense upon hearing
firearm discharging in response to the
physical confrontations public sentiment
and media coverage is polarized a trial
is scheduled to begin november 1. okay
so monday we will start full
comprehensive coverage and by that i
mean if i'm not too busy i'll stream
some of it comprehensive wall-to-wall
coverage of the kyle rittenhouse trial
now
what has been the big news this week
first of all i have to tell you and
we're gonna look at some audio here
from a two and a half hour we're gonna
look at video and then listen to the
audio of a hearing and you're gonna
start i'm not going to tell you what
you're going to feel
i am feeling as though this is maybe not
a judge who is going to really
be
uh a fair arbiter of this trial i'm
already very concerned about this judge
and we're going to talk about that in a
moment but one of the things that has
been decided and we're going to look at
a short cnn segment about it here the
judge has said the two people that were
killed can't be referred to as victims
during the trial
what okay let's listen set to go on
trial next week for murder the teenager
killed two people in kenosha wisconsin
during protests last year in the
aftermath of the jacob blake police
shooting
now what has a lot of people paying
attention this morning is is a pretty
controversial decision by the judge in a
pre-trial hearing as there were some
ground rules set that the prosecution is
not happy with
word victim is a loaded loaded word
and i think alleged victim is a cousin
to it
let the evidence show what the evidence
shows and if the evidence shows that any
or
more than
one of these
people were engaging in
arson
rioting or looting
looting i'm not going to tell the
defense they can't call them that
[Laughter]
so
okay you guys you guys understand what's
going on right
the prosecution is not allowed to call
the people killed by written house
neither victims nor alleged victims
they can't even argue that that's what
they are even though it's a murder trial
if kyle rittenhouse committed murder the
victims are the two people that were
killed can't do it
however
the defense which is going to argue that
this was self-defense of bad people and
why would they be talking about arson
etc
the the dead people
who have not been
uh charged
tried or convicted of arson or any of
these other things the judge is saying
well the defense if they can show
that they were arsonists they can call
them arsonists during the trial
but wait a second
neither of those has been determined
by a jury why so this is already
concerning
okay early start co-anchor and attorney
and legal reporter laura jarrett joins
us now let me just make crystal clear
what happened there in case people
didn't get it
the judge just said that the people kyle
rittenhouse killed and there's no
dispute over the fact that he killed him
they cannot be called victims the people
that he killed they can the judge says
however be called rioters and looters
and that's the part i think people are
finding so disturbing the prosecution is
calling it a double standard yes and in
reality they're dead they cannot defend
themselves at this trial right and
typically
when there's an agreement that somebody
has been harmed in some way injured or
been killed
victim is an accepted term there are
defense lawyers who've been arguing for
years that it is prejudicial um that it
implies guilt and that it taints the
jury's mind courts are split on this
jury instructions use the term victim
all the time some people define it in
different ways um but at the bottom here
what you're pointing out is that the
judge took it a step further by saying
that the people who died should be cast
in the light for the crimes that they
committed when in fact people go to jail
for killing people who commit crimes all
the time and so i think that's the part
that's really got people's attention and
if you're the prosecutor on the case
you're gonna say this is extremely
prejudicial um but there's not much they
can do about it because remember if kyle
riddenhaus gets off on this if he's
found not guilty they cannot oh he's
getting off on all of it i can assure
you retry him yeah there's not an appeal
for the prosecution that's not how it
works exactly and so
it's interesting i think you know one of
the things to remember is why is this
even coming up right um ridden house is
gonna say self-defense he's going to say
i was so afraid from all of these
looters and arsonists but evidence 101
tells you that is not going to fly and
that's why this evidence shouldn't have
been let in because whether someone was
setting fire to a building nearby should
have no bearing on whether kyle
redenhaus was afraid for his life and
okay so
that gives us one idea of the type of
thing that they're going to try to pull
before we get to more on that
speaking of the word victim here is a
daily wire guy i think this is matt
walsh i don't know it's one of the those
toxic daily wire guys here he says
actually the real victim here is kyle
rittenhouse
kyle rittenhouse should not have felt
the need to patrol the street with a gun
not because there was no need but
because there should not have been a
need
the blm mobs never should have been
allowed to reign terror and destruction
for weeks and months on end
in response to a police shooting that
was completely justified
the police should have done their jobs
they should have been allowed to do the
jobs
those in charge of establishing and
enforcing law and order should have done
so
they're the ones to blame for all this
ultimately
so if anyone should be on trial in the
kyle rittenhouse case it shouldn't be
kyle rittenhouse it should be the mayor
of kenosha
and the governor of wisconsin
so listen i see people in the chat
starting to say you're wrong and destiny
is right on this listen guys
i am not saying
that the facts support a guilty murder
verdict for kyle rittenhouse
i don't know
exactly what kenny two's position is on
this right now i think that given the
facts it's completely plausible that
written house goes free
and it would be consistent with the
story the defense is going to be able to
tell
i'm agreeing
that given the totality of the situation
and the standard for guilt of beyond a
shadow of a doubt i am already
very much leaning in the direction that
there is going to be a shadow of a doubt
as to whether this was self-defense and
i believe that kyle rittenhouse is going
to go free
and i'm not saying
morally anything about it he shouldn't
have been there he's a radicalized kid
had no business being in wisconsin to
begin with had no business getting
involved but he's
a hundred and twenty percent
sadly
given the circumstances that we know to
have been the circumstances i believe
his attorneys will within the bounds of
the law successfully cast doubt as to
whether this was murder
and make enough of a case that it could
have been self-defense that it will be
an acquittal so i don't think i'm
all the people saying david david you're
just completely wrong you got to talk to
destiny the last time i spoke to destiny
i think we were more or less on the same
page about that
okay shouldn't have had a gun shouldn't
have been there shouldn't be defending a
business shouldn't have been involved in
this shouldn't have been in the state
etc etc etc this is a kid who
serious problems radicalize etc but
good defense lawyers can probably argue
that this was at least maybe
self-defense and i think he goes free i
hate to say that so early okay now let's
get into the details of exactly the
types of moves that are trying to be
made here okay now i think the judge is
a problem
but
one of the things that's at issue here
is
this is all pre-trial remember the trial
starts on monday
the defense wants to introduce at the
trial which starts monday
evidence
which is
police officers earlier in the day
seeing written house
and not
stopping him
taking his gun or whatever
now
that's not actually relevant to whether
he killed these two people in
self-defense it was hours later
but we already know why the defense
counsel wants to have
this evidence entered which is earlier
in the day around lunchtime or whatever
officers bumped into written house and
said we really appreciate you doing what
you're doing and the prosecution you're
going to hear in this clip argue hold on
earlier in the day
this guy was on private property
protecting a business
the fact that at that time he wasn't
obviously committing a crime has no
connection to whether he later committed
murder or self-defense
and this is going to become an argument
here so let's look at this let me say
thank you before we do that to mickey r
who just signed up on my website thank
you mickey also ryan oglesby new member
on my website members 15 and 16 today
over on twitch thank you to tamp street
91
as well as liquid ice 55 new members 17
and 18. liquid ice says shave with hair
conditioner it'll change your life
guilty on some counts or mistrial the
case should have been moved to another
district yeah we talk about that on
today's award-winning bonus show obama
and uh yeah i think that there is not
going to be a guilty verdict on murder
maybe something else may be mistrial i
don't believe we're gonna get a guilty
verdict on murder so let's just get into
this this is a two and a half hour video
we're not going to watch all of it but
this is interesting stuff just keep just
stick with this because you're going to
start to get a sense of what's at issue
here what the defense has planned
so then we need to get to 34. so
there'll be uh yeah
12 more
which will be 6 and six
and you fellas will be back there until
we start the trial okay wait this isn't
it
which i think it's here let's see
encountered the defendant on the evening
uh here we go okay
check this out
this is where it starts
in the meantime why don't we take up
this motion for a protective order
regarding officer
frankel
uh is the motion opposed
it is
okay um mr bigger
your honor i filed this motion regarding
one of the witnesses that's been listed
by the defense amanda franco
the basis for this motion is that the
officer here has virtually no connection
to the case
the
officer encountered the defendant on the
evening of this incident
had a couple of very brief and cordial
conversations with him because she had
recognized him
from the incident uh from june of last
year
which was the subject of our other acts
motion and the court has already ruled
on that motion the court has already uh
ruled that the state is not going to be
allowed to introduce evidence regarding
that incident and just to refresh the
court's memory that was an incident in
which there's an allegation that the
defendant's sister was involved in a
one-on-one fight with another female and
during that fight the defendant
intervened on behalf of his sister
essentially turning it into a two-on-one
fight
um and i argued that it went to the
issue of self-defense because the
defense the defendant was uh purportedly
trying to assist his sister this is
actually not the section i wanted to
deal with let's see if it's the next one
i doubt she would have had any
interaction whatsoever so i i don't know
what the relevance of this is and i
guess if this if the defense wants to
introduce this evidence i would ask that
there'd be some sort of offer see if i
can find it i bookmarked it hold on
[Music]
apologize everybody what do you want for
fifty thousand dollars right
um
but uh anyway
judge he's charged with reckless he's
charged with uh multiple counts of
reckless behavior right we're gonna find
it just give me a second when you are
listening to the evidence and the jury
is making a determination
okay
it's around the 25 minute mark let me
take a look here
the entire police presence on that
evening
is business and when the police say
things okay here we go he's made that
decision
um so i think i think this is exactly
where i thought that the defense would
be going it's one of the subjects of one
of my motions in lemonade your honor
it's uh this is it i believe motion
number three
um and it uh seeks to um
just make sure uh
it's number four he gets to it they get
this is the part where they get to this
can they talk about what other
uninvolved officers said to kyle
rittenhouse earlier in the day as if
that has anything to do with whether he
acted in self-defense later i'm kind of
mis-numbered it's number four and uh
that's part of my motion in lemonade
here which is that uh the defense should
not be allowed to
actually no it's not number four
it's number five it's uh number five
actually there you go it's the motion
eliminate talks about
whether or not
anonymous law enforcement officers made
statements earlier in the evening
regarding the defendant's activities
or whether or not they
talked about their plans in terms of
crowd control or things like that
and this is not a trial about the police
activities it's not a trial about police
tactics
it's not a trial about whether or not
law enforcement that night
took action or didn't take action this
is a case about what the defendant did
that night
and i'm concerned that this is going to
be turned into a trial over the what law
enforcement should or shouldn't have
done that night and i don't think that
that's
what this court worth is trial should be
deciding so this is these are two good
points actually so what the defense
wants is to introduce hey listen earlier
in the day kyle rittenhouse ran into
these police officers or these police
officers ran into kyle rittenhouse and
they didn't think he was doing anything
wrong they thought that his behavior was
absolutely and completely fine
etc etc as
evidence that later in the day
written house also was behaving
perfectly
and as the prosecutor here suggests
it may be a way to back door and make
this about did police have control of
kenosha that night or not as if that has
a bearing on whether kyle rittenhouse
acted in self-defense or not the
prosecutor is saying that really
shouldn't be allowed let's continue
oh i'm not are we arguing the motions in
lemonade now yeah okay very well
so number um no i guess we're just doing
number
five right now
oh
um
i don't need it for this one
so yeah he says he says four you say
five it's like protestant versus
catholic with the ten commandments so
this is my understanding so there is a
in the video there is a statement by a
police officer who says an unidentified
police officer saying
uh we appreciate you guys we really do
now what mr binger
initially said is that's
hearsay
now we are obviously not offering it for
the truth it's not here
we can discuss it again at the trial but
just to save time this afternoon it's
not your saying i agree
so and what would i laid out for the
court and
i just want the state to understand this
that no one is saying
that because the police whatever however
they reacted
that mr rittenhouse was lawful and
justified that is not a defense to a
charge
but ah
mr binger has chosen to charge reckless
conduct
okay
he's made that decision so what the
defense attorney's trying to back door
is say listen no no no no no
we're not going to say
that because
an officer
found no issue with his behavior earlier
in the day
that he's not guilty of murder we're not
going to say that but
because reckless conduct is part of the
charges
his behavior earlier if not reckless
maybe would be part of what a jury would
consider which is essentially the same
thing
now he has to be able to show the
defendant's conduct should an utter
disregard for human life all i've done
is look at the jury instruction on what
a fact finder is supposed to consider
when making that determination your
honor
and if you look at that instruction
they are to consider what the defendant
was doing
why he was engaged in that conduct how
dangerous that conduct was how obvious
the danger was
whether the conduct shows disregard for
life
and all other facts and circumstances
related to that conduct and i would
submit to you
conversations
interactions that he has with law
enforcement
go to his state of mind as to whether or
not hey how obvious that danger was
there you go um and whether it was
actually dangerous conduct so that so
he's he's saying we're actually
you got us we really are gonna do
exactly what the prosecutor is worried
we're gonna do
but it's okay because i'm phrasing it in
a different way
those are relevant factors to determine
reckless behavior and when he has
conversations with police officers and
they
let him go about his business and when
the police say things like they've said
on that tape
those go to his state of mind they are
absolutely relevant for the charge of
reckless he is charged with three
different counts of reckless behavior in
this case
so
the way that mr bringer has chosen to
charge the case has opened up
in our view has opened up the facts and
circumstances surrounding what had
happened
because the totality of the
circumstances go into play in
determining whether or not behavior is
chosen under disregard for human life
and that's what we're saying of us
now the reason i said it isn't hearsay
and i don't want to get an extensive
discussion about it and we can do it at
the time of the trial
but
hearsay is uh
everybody's already on in agreement
about the hearsay part but the judge
goes back to it anyway
is evidence offered
to prove the truth of the matter
asserted
and there is also an exception for
a plan or a
present intent
i don't want to get too deeply into this
but you denounced it as irrelevant to
hearsay the relevance is open to
question
but i don't think it's hearsay
because it's not being proved
at least i would not permit it to be
used to prove
that the entire police presence on that
evening
appreciated
mr rittenhouse's behavior
or his presence or whatever
whatever i don't i don't think it's here
i i don't want to get bogged down on
that relevance is another matter
but he's addressed that do you want to
respond to that i do
um this would be akin to a police
officer um telling mr rittenhouse at 1
pm that he stopped at a stop sign
properly
and that's used as evidence to show that
at 10 pm uh when he
shoots and kills people that somehow
he's not reckless right they're remote
in time they're remote behavior they
they have no
bearing on one another whatsoever
the evidence with regard to these
statements by anonymous law enforcement
officers occurred earlier in the evening
at a separate location with regard to
separate behavior and
no one is going to argue in this case
that the defendant was reckless or
unjustified in desiring to protect
private property
remaining at a private business location
and trying to secure that location that
is something that countless people in
kenosha did that night and many nights
around that time period whether it was
their own home or their business
or their neighborhood and they are well
within their rights to do so
the activities that we're talking about
in this trial did not occur
at that location they did not occur on
private property right they did not
occur in the course of protecting that
business
they occurred blocks away
far away from the location that mr
rittenhouse took it upon himself to
guard that night
when he's out wandering on his own
without any members of his group nearby
and he is getting himself involved in
things that are well beyond his purview
this occurred the shootings that we're
going to talk about this trial occurred
well beyond the police lines
outside of the view of what was the law
in kenosha
south of 60th street on that night
because when you were here last time
you uh
used you were talking about
the
police zone that the police had pushed
people back
presumably to protect the public
buildings in this area i'm with you guys
this seems like a hostile hostile judge
i totally agree
but what was the status of law
enforcement self-evident i mean
or down 60th street where there was
enormous amount of looting in arson
what was the state of law
in those areas
there wasn't much absolutely i agree
your honor the police had made a
decision that night that their resources
would not allow them to
get into this area and try and
arrest every criminal stop every crime
take care we're talking about arson
you're honest to be honest the the arson
that night uh you're the the primary
arson
in this time period occurred on the
nights before on this particular night
there's very little arson there's a
dumpster there is a trailer that's
strange literal dumpster fire down the
road over on 60th i think what you're
referring to is over about 15th or 16th
and 60th right before the embankment
there's a car dealership and i think the
owners of the car dealership actually
piled a bunch of tires in the middle of
their parking lot and set them on fire
for some reason didn't damage any cars
or anything like that yeah so anyway you
guys get the picture of where where this
is going so
the trial starts monday um we'll be
covering a bunch of it live as much as
as much as is possible
um
we are uh we are banning people who just
come through trolling with free kyle
rittenhouse that's not um
i don't consider that good faith
participation i've said i think they can
probably create
uh enough doubt that this is gonna be
not guilty but just trolling through my
twitch channel or my youtube channel
free kyle rittenhouse or kyle written
house hero we're just not gonna allow it
okay so i just banned another person for
that um and we're gonna um we're gonna
continue to do that okay i've just been
sent a uh
an alert of shots fired on the sam cedar
program
let's take
let's see what happened here this was
sent by nug wrangler things and and to
identify the real enemies
um
which you know is and always has been
david pakman i mean honestly
do you really even like apples if your
favorite apple is a granny smith apple
oh my god not the granny smith stuff
again
i don't know
it raises a lot of questions
honestly like it sounds to me like the
guys probably never even had an apple
[Laughter]
granny smith right
yeah i think that's true and also
hey by the way it seems like something
is the light deliberately darkened on
emma like why is she sitting in the dark
can't sam put a light on her for crying
out loud it's almost like it's reverse
lighting it's bright around her and
they've got her sitting in front of a
shadow are they deliberately casting a
shadow on emma's face
bizarre lighting decision
it's like uh the usual suspects right
like it's like it's as if he was asked
it like uh you know like he had like
somebody asked him on twitter what's
your favorite apple and he just happened
to be in like a 7-eleven and he looked
around he goes uh granny smith
i have to do with the usual scenes
because that's the way you saw like you
know that scene in the last uh scene
and he's looking around the office and
that's how he came up with kaiser jose
and the whole story oh okay yeah all
right
i mean why are there sirens going on the
entire i just realized this whole
segment there's been sirens in the
background it's kind of it gives off
some ted bundy vibes
wow okay yeah no that's a pretty those
are pretty serious allegations i'm not
gonna lie okay one other thing here and
here i have a request for you guys i'm
asking you oh hold on and but before i
even do that
huge thank you
to yuri 1q1q
as well as cody schumacher
for signing up via twitch prime numbers
19 and 20 today
also thank you to garrett reitz who just
signed up on my website joinpackman.com
using the coupon code elements of
bathrooms elements of bathrooms if
you've been thinking of supporting the
streams please do it today today is
really a great day to do it you go to
joinpakman.com you save 69
with the coupon code elements of
bathrooms elements of bathrooms okay
donald trump put out this statement
today and i i am coming to you for help
um
it's it's almost like a uh it's a it's
almost like a sentence fragment trump
put out a statement chanting we love
trump in arlington virginia thank you
arlington see you soon this is being
interpreted as trump might actually show
up in virginia in the next six days to
campaign for glenn younkin in this
crucial
pivotal
critical of virginia gubernatorial
election
if anybody hears that trump is going to
rally in virginia with yunkan
please let me know so i can make sure to
clear my schedule and cover it because
it would be cuckoo for coco puffs
bonkers insane if that happens unclear
which of the two of them is the craziest
if that happens but please let me know
um because i definitely want to um
want to cover that okay let me now
get to what i teased earlier i received
a very strange voicemail
from a viewer about my last interaction
with stephen kenneth destiny bonnell ii
i'll just play it with no further
introduction
hey davey this is richie from california
so
i'm just curious about what exactly your
relationship is with uh
kenneth destiny bonnell junior
frederickson douglas i don't know
uh just you know
i'm kind of new to the whole well not
new i've been for a little while now a
couple years but i
you're my guy
in the youtube political world after
seeing your your interview with vosh i
got i started watching him
you know i'm not a socialist but
whatever i think he's got a lot of good
arguments and he's a great uh
broadcaster he's got a good voice i dig
vosh too um
like i'm not really familiar with the
with all the characters in this little
game and i get kind of lost in the drama
sometimes i find it very entertaining
watching i know you keep out of that
world but i watch vosh get into it but
like
but my history besides you know voss's
issues with destiny my you know
my first interaction with him was on one
of your live streams i think it was
during the blm riots whatever it was
right after the
the
kyle rittenhouse thing that he got into
but it seems like every time you have
him on he's just like
you said it that one time on your own
he's just shot out of a [ __ ] cannon
and he seems like an angry guy and just
and it seems like you know and it seems
like you know maybe it's just because
you're a nice guy but it seems like like
you're you're only thing
like you're always just you know like
you're great pals or something like that
but it seems like the only thing you
have to point to is that once you had a
dinner with him in a song
oh we also had brunch and at the brunch
actually this is here too for
unpublicized data
um
at the brunch i had with stephen kenneth
destiny bonnell ii
uh he ordered a side of bacon
and a side of sausage
uh and i said
kenny that's a lot of pork
that's a lot of pork
i don't know i mean what is your
relationship with him that he's he's
such a great guy that like you just
[ __ ] keep giving him passes i guess
is my question what is this guy talking
about
um
what what on earth is he talking about
anyway all right very good so we figured
that out uh ginger double-oh-seven thank
you for the twitch prime subscription
appreciate that
uh but what a what what a i don't know
very very all wrapped up in it let's do
a couple more okay but hold on before i
get to voicemails let me do a few super
chats it's hilarious arlington was biden
plus 64 in 2020. thank you
nug wrangler upholding american
democracy it depends what happened
before the released video
have you seen the video of ted cruz
defending nazi salutes at a school board
meeting yeah let's let's look at that
ted cruz nazi
check this out account just sitting here
during this hearing i counted 20
incidents cited
of the 20
15 on their face are non-violent
they involve things like insults they
involve a nazi salute
that's one of the examples my god a
parent did a nazi salute at a school
board because he thought the the
policies were oppressive
general garland is doing a nazi salute
and elected official is that protected
by the first amendment yes it is okay
it's still trivialization of it's not
exactly what i'd be defending it's still
trivialization of the holocaust it's
you know so many different things very
weird um
example
uh very very odd stuff
isn't it illegal for a 17 year old to
bear arms you know at this point i don't
even i i think regardless of his age i
don't think written house is allowed to
bring
guns from illinois into wisconsin i
think that's at issue
um he had a machine gun how was he
scared for his life
either way he illegally possessed a
firearm i don't believe he had a machine
gun he had a rifle right
if we only stipulate pending facts that
kyle didn't break any laws prior to
being chase would he have to submit
himself to mob justice right it doesn't
make any sense
i don't normally sympathize with
prosecutors but this is outrageous what
else when else is such latitude given to
the defense
david sir the only conclusion i can come
to is that mike pillow has paid this
judge off
david i'm from kenosha we are a small
town i work down the road from where
rittenhouse shot his gun i heard the
bullets fire at home traumatizing wow
hey fellow progressives
garrett says i hope kyle rittenhouse
goes free but don't mind hearing you out
whoa
can't say after what i've read before
this that the judge for the trial is
trustworthy
um
yeah
a lot of really really crazy stuff going
on
thank you to island twig
for the twitch prime subscription
beautiful subscription also thank you to
matthew speedy for signing up on my
website using the code elements of
bathrooms elements of bathrooms your new
member number 24 today let's do a few um
a few voicemails i haven't done any
today let's just see what we've got of
course whitney is in the voicemail
i think like the best plan of action to
um
from
protecting our genders
would be to
enforce like drug regulations i think
that we should bring back the war on
drugs and then might promote stuff like
cbd and
all right here's the egg man
hi dave
in the years i've been listening to your
show
you've been very persuasive in changing
my mind about hate crime enhancements
and the death penalty
dave you're great at being a convincer
but darn it dave you will never convince
me to get rid of gas powered lawn mowers
are you out of your mind dave how the
heck will i cut my lawn with a
battery-powered lawnmower i have acres
dave acres it takes me hours and it's a
half a day with a riding lawnmower and a
50 inch deck and a couple gallons of gas
i hate it i get it
but how do i cut my lawn how do
businesses in california maintain
stay open this is a lawn care business a
battery-powered lawnmower
dear lord also a leaf blower uses as
much fuel as a car driving from
california to colorado dave that's
[ __ ] okay that is just it's
absolutely impossible if people can feel
like donald trump won the election
because he had so much presence on
social media i feel like a leaf blower
is not nearly as powerful as a
four-cylinder toyota all right so eggman
completely shot out of a cannon
um so i think that maybe ivanka could be
like queen of mother earth though
because she could get like that crunchy
hippie vibe going you know for the
environment
and you know get those people because
she has like a voice but super down to
earth you know okay i don't know what
that's about
hi david this is andrew d
and i got a call from a friend last
night
and she was telling me that the virus is
a psyop
and that she's not getting baxed and
then it's a sigh up by the 100 richest
people in the world
and i asked her to name
any of these 100 wealthiest people who
invented this virus well done which she
said i think the rockefellers
something else but anyway
still convincing these people she was
like convinced me otherwise i'm like i
i have nothing
i mean i just kind of threw my hands in
the air she was super [ __ ] up sorry
she was very drunk
all right well that's interesting i
guess
but um i think that like uh trump's sons
should go do something like telescheme
and i feel like that would be like a
really good influence in society to be
like i think if every trump supporter
went heli-skiing we would have no more
trump supporters yeah
david
love you love your show
uh i am a neocon but i do love your show
love your point of view
but uh i'm concerned like many who voted
never trump
uh well got buyer's remorse with biden
that he's giving to the progressives and
i'm i'm afraid that a lot of my uh
brethren never trumpers
won't be there for the democrats in 22
and 24
and may you know dance with the devil
yeah i completely agree i think it's
going to be very very tough in 24. i've
said it whether it's biden or harris i
think it's tough
so i was reading up about um how in
georgia they were arrested for shredding
a voter registration forms
all right very good
hi david
um
do you think this
knew a stunt from donald trump is that
he's going to start his own party i
actually don't think he's going to i
don't think he's going to do that
so
um
what's like the likelihood that trump
could say like
um
you know he's gonna
ruin everybody's lives and ruin
our chances of success
at
being able to pick an authority that
will end the transgender safely i think
it's very likely he would do that
hey david my name is james california
um calling in i just
watched your
video of trump tells republicans not to
vote in 2024
uh
i couldn't stop laughing at your
response
when you
when he said that
the thousand students will not vote
in twenty
two and twenty okay
thank you appreciate it
hey david it's uh my name is tim i'm a
recent member watched your show all the
time have for the past year
i'm also canadian
that's okay and uh
i feel bad for all you americans it's uh
we no longer have any inferiority
complex with regards to your politics
versus ours sure
uh that being said i think
the point of trump telling
people not to vote
is being largely missed
i feel like it's directed at
his
republicans
in congress in the senate all right well
there's another perspective for sure
so like i noticed on trump's website
like okay so i go to biden's website and
like compare bretton's website to
trump's website like it's not even like
anything put in writing where um you
know things are even like supposed to go
a certain way or
you know
or it's just like he's saying like oh
he'll protect innocent life and he's
like judeo christian
all right unfortunately we're going
maybe from bad to worse because here is
eric from mass
hey david it's ever from mass uh i just
wanted to tell you uh called [ __ ] on
all the science crap
um there's an oxygen slash co2 reader if
you put it under a mask it proves
that co2 is
uh
being sucked back in when you breathe
it's going to cause cancer it's going to
cause brain damage
these are facts scientific facts
um also well this is really weaponized
you say nobody's
got hurt or died from the vaccine nba
player brandon goodwin had to retire
blood clots people don't get blood clots
at 22 years old
three cyclists just had to retire hot
issues
an ex-bruin just died an ex-new orlean
saint just died um two nhl active nhl
players just had to retire from heart
issues see this is this is the sam
harris it's very hard to be putting out
small fires all the time with these
people
very very tough um we'll go back to wit
then another call from eric
so there's researching more about
pragmaticism versus um
uh
different like debates or ideology
and um theories and stuff like that as
far as like creative thoughts
and right and then back to eric
trust the science trust the science
sanjay gupta goes on joe rogan gets
obliterated
proves ivermectin works proves they lied
proves over and over and you sit there
you know it's funny
in a conversation
between joe rogan and sanjay gupta
neither one of them can prove or
disprove that ivormectin works or
doesn't work
they can reference studies that might
demonstrate that but this is like
another example of how like
the linguistic confusion that a lot of
these people experience it's not just
linguistic it's not just semantic they
actually believe
that in a conversation between two
people sitting at a desk
it can be proven that ivermectin does or
doesn't work ivormectin's efficacy for
any particular application
would be proven or disproven via
placebo-controlled randomized trials two
guys talking about it doesn't do the
proving and this is this is like it's
it's a mind it's you know you'd be like
oh that's that's that's nitpicking
it's really not it's really not because
it's actually core
they think the conversation can prove or
disprove something whereas it's really
that's the science that would
so um when i was researching economics
like i kept running into like um english
people like me too no in my economics
career just that the brits they were
everywhere
hey david and sarah from mass again i
just wanted to uh
enlighten you on the argument you make
of these vaccines and stuff all this uh
going to school and whatnot
uh with the mandatory or whatever with
going to school with chickenpox and
measles all that stuff
whatever uh
those are immunizations
do you
understand the difference
immunizations
means
they work 99 or higher
this don't
so
okay
hey i just realized that i didn't finish
this book that you
suggested reading
all right well still time no question
about that
hi david my name is stephanie i'm 32
from michigan
um
i just wanted to
make a comment about the colin powell
situation and how
some people might see his death as a
reason to not get vaccinated but one
point that
um i didn't hear you make yesterday and
i'm sorry if you've covered it already
is that
uh colin powell had a
an immune situation yeah yeah so we
we've talked about this so much you're
absolutely right stephanie we've we've
just talked about it a lot a lot a lot a
lot i want to say thank you to wait for
it for subscribing via twitch prime
number 25 today
also a huge thank you to felice
deangelis for signing up on my website
joinpackman.com
so that's going to do it for today we
have the kyle rittenhouse trial starting
live monday we will be covering it also
thanks to jeffrey glover just saw
jeffrey glover signed up on my website i
may be streaming tomorrow and friday
unsure yet but we will be here with you
on monday for the start of the kyle
rittenhouse trial
great to see everybody four streams in a
row
and much more coming clips are
publishing tonight we're actually
dumping a bunch of content in the next
few hours so check it out see everybody
very
soon you